[Music]
since the birth of this great nation men
and women have fought died to protect
their freedoms in which we all have so
much pride and as a spill their blood
and Gettysburg say freedom is what they
saw and it gasps the dying Patriot he
will tell you that they fought for
random screenings at the airport with
the TSA all grabby while we place our
tour the trees out in transparent
plastic baggies and plastic why they
fought and dies it give you the same
answer
seeking pics taken of your junk while
slowly getting cancer asking any single
one of them it won't be no surprise
that's why they bought that will they
brave the cold and Valley Forge face and
sacrifice and pain here there was
typhoid measles dysentery plus being in
Pennsylvania but they went to fight the
British to save this independent nation
and with their final words they say they
dad so our taxation could be on property
and it come with the holding of our
wages with the silly complex tax code
over 16,000 pages and if questioned why
they gave their lives they'd say their
only wishes we could fill out seven
forms to prove that Ansel was for
business
ask any single one of them it won't be
no surprise that's why they fought died
they gave their lives well we could save
a forum or get food they storm at Sandy
Bay so we could pay our neighbors to
they fought and died and fields with
pride and gave us all we hope for
to save us all from tyranny and also
from 4lo ask any single one of them it
won't be no surprise that's why they
both die that's why they wanna die
that's why they both died
that's why they both died
[Music]